bonsoir mesdames et messieurs
saviez-vous
que vous côtoyez chaque jour un monde
dont vous ignorez l'existence alors
qu'il se trouve juste sous vos yeux ce
monde c'est celui des mousses ou
bryophytes pour les intimes
les mousses ce sont ces petites plantes
vertes qui pousse sur l'as sur le sol
sur les arbres sur les pierres au milieu
de votre gazon sur les murs sur le toit
de votre maison ou encore entre les
dalles de votre terrasse et aussi dans
ce pot à côté de moi mais c'est
tellement plus que cela les mousses pour
moi c'est d'abord le sujet de mon
travail de master à l'université où je
les étudie dans un milieu particulier
une raison une région extrêmement sèche
au brésil mais c'est tellement plus que
cela c'est aussi une passion une passion
qui est née alors que je faisais mon
collège et que j'ai dû préparer mon tout
premier posters scientifiques sur les
mousses c'est une passion qui grandit
chaque jour et qui me pousse à vouloir
en apprendre davantage et surtout à
devenir ambassadrice des mousses dans le
monde afin de pouvoir en parler au plus
de monde au plus de personnes possible
car c'est une passion qui m'a amené à
une prise de conscience en fait une
prise de conscience existentielle saviez
vous que si vous êtes ici ce soir c'est
aussi grâce aux mousses saviez vous que
ce monde tels que nous les connaissons
tel qu'il existe
c'est aussi grâce aux mousses et pour le
voir nous devons aller au-delà
au delà de nos a priori au delà de
l'idée que les plantes font simplement
partie du décor
au delà de l'idée que les arbres et les
fleurs sont les seuls plantes qui mérite
notre considération et à ce moment là
à ce moment là seulement nous pouvons
voir les mousses à ce moment là nous
pouvons saisir leur importance évolutive
historique et écologique
à ce moment là nous pouvons saisir
l'essence même des mousses et c'est ce
que je voudrais vous partagez ce soir la
caractéristique des mousses ce sont les
premières plantes terrestres sorti de
l'eau il y as 400 millions d'années
avant elle
toutes les plantes et et aquatiques
c'étaient les algues et après elles il y
a eu tout le reste
que ce soit les fougères les conifères
les fleurs toutes les plantes que nous
mangeons toutes les plantes que nous
utilisons pour nous vêtir pour nous
chauffer pour nous soigner tout cela ce
sont des descendants de ses ancêtres
mousse sortie des eaux
mais la transition entre l'eau et l'air
n'a pas été facile il a fallu faire face
à de nombreuses barrières
car cela a un coût de vivre sur terre
c'est un coup vis-à-vis de la radiation
du soleil c'est un coup vis-à-vis de la
sécheresse du gel des glissements de
terrain des variations climatiques et
les mousses pour cela ont mis en place
un système extraordinaire
pardon avant qu'elle puisse compter sur
les sur les continents il a fallu faire
face à sète problème de la radiation
solaire et ceci a pu être fait grâce à
un événement qui a eu lieu bien avant
l'existence des mousses cet événement
s'appelle la grande oxydation qui s'est
produite il y à un milliard d'années
imaginez un monde où toute vie est
aquatique
car les rayons du soleil notamment les
ultraviolets stérilise entièrement les
terres émergées
à cette période il y à deux milliards
d'années il y à une surproduction
d'oxygène faites par les micro
organismes aquatiques les cyanobactéries
grâce à la photosynthèse
mais l'oxygène c'est un polluant pour
ces organismes
ce qui provoque la première grande crise
écologique planétaire qui change
complètement toutes les conditions
vitales de la planète car l'oxygène
commence par s'accumuler dans l'eau puis
il finit par partir dans l'atmosphère
est là en route altitude
il réagit avec les rayons ultraviolets
qui viennent du soleil et cela forme une
couche protectrice la couche d'ozone et
c'est cette couche qui permettra aux
mousses de pouvoir monter sur la terre
ferme est en fait à plein d'autres
organismes comme les lichens ou les
champignons et les bactéries
car cette couche stop une partie des
rayons ultraviolets et dans l'espace et
qu'une fine parti qui permet cette ville
mais au moment où les mousses arrive sur
la terre ferme
elles font face à un problème qu'elle
n'avait pas encore vu ce problème c'est
celui de la sécheresse mais elle met en
place une capacité une capacité
extraordinaire
alors accrochez vous cette capacité
s'appelle la poésie kg iddri c'est un
mot que vous pourrez utiliser la
prochaine fois que vous jouerez au
scrabble la politique et idriss et cette
capacité ne pouvoir se dessécher
complètement et de se réhydrater en
fonction de l'humidité ambiante
en fait c'est ce que nous ne pouvons pas
faire si je prends une mousse sèche et
brunes et que je la mouille en quelques
minutes elle redeviendra verte elle
recommencera à faire de la photosynthèse
si je prends une momie égyptienne et que
je la mouiller
non seulement il ne se passera rien mais
en plus j'aurais le département
d'archéologie sur le dos pour
dégradations delà du patrimoine culturel
mais attention la poly kg iddri ce n'est
pas une incapacité à retenir l'eau c'est
une révolution adaptative
car lorsqu elles sont sèches et tout
renfermée sur elle même
les mousses protègent leurs mater leurs
marques matériel génétique et elle
permet cela leur permet également de
pouvoir survivre à des températures
allant jusqu'à 50 degrés et même des
températures en dessous de zéro comme en
antarctique
évidemment
toute médaille a son revers est le gros
défaut de la poésie kg iddri c'est que
lorsque les mousses sont sèches elles
sont en pause métaboliques
ce qui fait qu'elles ne peuvent plus
grandir ainsi par exemple les mousses en
antarctique
une mousse de 6 cm peut être vieille de
500 ans parce qu'elle n'aura été capable
de pousser de faire de la photosynthèse
que 1 millimètre par an reprenons
l'exemple du gazon vous souvenez ce
gazon ou les mousses qui pousse
généralement on souhaite les enlever et
bien en fait les mousses qui pousse dans
votre gazon elle ne les trouve pas elle
n'empêche pas le gazon de pousser c'est
tout simplement parce que le gazon lui
même n'arrive pas à pousser à cet
endroit car la mousse à une rythme de
croissance tellement lent par rapport à
celui du gazon qu'elle ne ferait pas le
poids
une caractéristique primordiale des
mousses c'est que ce sont des plantes
pionnières
ainsi grâce aussi à cette capacité de la
peau et kg iddri on les trouve dans une
diversité de milieux extraordinaire que
ce soit au bord de l'eau au sommet des
montagnes à l'équateur au pôle sur des
tuiles en terre cuite ou sur un bout de
tissu au milieu d'une forêt comme celui
que j'ai trouvé lorsque j'étais au
brésil
ces plantes pionnières lorsqu'un milieu
et détruit par exemple par une éruption
volcanique
ce sont les premières plantes qu'ils
pourront revenir parce qu'elles n'ont
pas besoin elles n'ont pas de racines
elles n'ont pas besoin des nutriments
présents dans le sol et elles vont
pouvoir former ce premier russe qui
ensuite permettra à toutes les autres
plantes de venir et de former une
nouvelle forêt
en somme s'il n'y avait pas eu les
mousses il n'y aurait pas eu d'arbres
s'il n'y avait pas eu d'arbres il n'y
aurait pas eu de primates
s'il n'y avait pas eu de primates il n'y
aurait pas eu d'humains et s'il n'y
avait pas eu d'humains nous ne serions
pas ici ce soir à pouvoir profiter d'un
tedx sur le thème de beyond s'il n'y
avait pas eu les mousses aucun d'entre
vous ne serez ici ce soir
aucun d'entre nous n'existerait ici
alors la prochaine fois que vous irez
vous promener dehors chercher les
mousses et quand vous les verrez ayez
cette pensée de reconnaissance car du
haut de cette mousse 400 millions
d'années d'évolution vous contemplent
[Applaudissements]